[Musique]
bonjour dans son caddie ce matin merci à
vous dit me en effet 2 bertrand dans ce
studio
bonjour bertrand buzy bonjour vous êtes
le premier secrétaire de la cstm la
centrale syndicale des travailleurs
martiniquais
alors pour la cstm l'année passée
l'année 2017 a été une année plutôt
active 1 pour votre syndicat on se
souvient notamment de la longue grève
qu'il ya eu dans l'entreprise vedette
tropicale et puis aussi d'un appel à la
grève générale en octobre dernier qui
avait pas été très très suivi 1
c'est vrai faut bien le dire alors vous
avez effectué une réunion de rentrée de
l'année civile à l'année 2018 vendredi
dernier une réunion de rentrée comme ça
c'est quoi c'est une bonne façon de
remobiliser les troupes bertrand cambuci
oui si besoin était alors il faut savoir
c'est tout d'abord c'est pour faire la
revue des troupes
deuxièmement faire le point sur l'année
écoulée et surtout tracer les
perspectives à venir
donc c'est le moment aussi de prendre
contact avec tourner tous les délégués
je rappelle que la commission exécutive
c'est quand même
l'ensemble des délégués dans les
entreprises un comité d'entreprise
délégué syndical s'est lâché ctdp et
cetera conseil des salariés également et
ce n'est qu'elle est titulaire puisque
les super n'ont pas de crédit doit
pouvoir se libérer lorsque ça se fait un
vendredi ou un jour dans la semaine mais
d'aborder aussi quelques changements
quelques transformations avec notamment
la réforme du code du travail qui est
intervenu dans le courant de l'année
dernière vous avez évoqué ça comment
vous envie jaser ça dans votre activité
syndicale
alors nous avons surtout analyser la
situation sur le plan social économique
et sa voix de sart globe tout puisque en
fait lorsque nous regardons la situation
par rapport à tous ces changements se
cette stratégie du gouvernement qui a
vidé
justement le code du travail de tout son
sens d'ailleurs nous avons des
spectateurs a pris aujourd'hui qui sont
désarmés parce que il faut savoir que si
vous avez un inspecteur du travail et
qui parce que
sa mission c'est de faire respecte le
droit aux si ce code du travail lui-même
rien et pouvoir protéger les
travailleurs ben c'est sûr et certain
pratiquement ça ne sert à nous avons
qu'est ce que nous avons fait nous avons
observée depuis plusieurs mois
d'ailleurs il ya une accélération des
ruptures conventionnelles
parce que justement il ya management
dans les entreprises qui est basée à
justement ce qui concerne l ça veut dire
que les représentants syndicaux sont
d'accord non pas du tout pas du tout
puisque je rappelle que la rupture
conventionnelle l'employeur propose aux
salariés ou le sai propose mais de la
manière dont c'est cette conscience
en tout cas les ruptures actuelle les
coûts individuels en individuel pas que
l'escroc qui actuellement la macworld
leur mac hoymille également aux petits
collectifs collective à la nature des
vocalises du individuel individuel
eh bien vous savez c'est pas compliqué
quand un employé audience salariés soit
vous faites parce qu'après lance le
harcèlement au travail
c'est quoi ces doigts de le lui dire et
bien vous êtes bien entraîné soit il ya
2 2 voies la première c'est surtout à
bien l'inaptitude professionnelle parce
qu'un salarié ne peut plus tenir sinon
d'un salarié et bien soin aux caprins
options mensuelles à la soie réalisation
et donc on a vu face à la pression
c'est tout ce changement du gouvernement
une coupante et au code du travail et
aujourd'hui les travailleurs sont
démunis et résultats ben quand la
pression commence à monter
il sollicite et on a vu qu'à une
accélération depuis le premier janvier
on a vu des liens encore jeune et encore
il ya beaucoup de salariés qui par
dompter convention je rappelle quand
même que là où tout fonctionne elle est
comme un assujetti à une autorisation de
l'inspecteur du travail
mais je veux dire c'est du cabinet
aujourd'hui tout le monde pardon à
obturation sans savoir au lendemain
alors ils sentent que vous avez vous
avez déjà dans l'objectif ou dans votre
collimateur une entreprise dès ce début
d'année puisque parmi les
et point à l'ordre du jour de cette
réunion de rentrée de vendredi dernier
vous mettiez le plan social et
économique de l'entreprise multi gros
avec trente licenciements peut-être oui
comme conséquence que vous prétendez lab
social qui a été mise en place par cette
entreprise parce que justement les
organisations syndicales a demandé des
documents dans dû faire appel à un
expert comptable et je rappelle que ces
35 milles au gallon entreprises ap parce
qu'il ya des rétentions d'informations
et donc on est obligé la loi nous le
permet de le faire deux par un expert
comptable mais surtout que ce que nous
constatons dans sur place cruciale sous
dix élus il ya c'est lui qui sont
concernés au toit m'a dit c'est là
syndicaux un liquid élu mardi que le
manque de la dupe c'est à dire les
membres du comité d'entreprise délégués
du ps cela voudrait dire quoi ça vous
dirait que se place aussi à la réalité
c'est une manière pour faire disparaître
la représentation du personnel parce que
quand vous avez sept élus sur dix qui
est quand même dans un plan social qui
est qui est concerné par le licenciement
des trois salariés
c'est quand même accessible et
d'ailleurs dans nos battent justement
pour faire échouer ce plan là d'accord
donc ça c'est l'une des premières
mobilisations à venir on va pas
s'étendre là dessus puisque le temps est
court bertrand cambuci vous avez aussi
exprimé la position de la csdm par
rapport à l'or au dossier du transport
en martinique alors est ce qu'elle est
c'est quoi votre position à la cst notre
position est le cas aujourd'hui
et derrière de nous avons entendu dans
la presse de vos confrères dire que le
transport notamment dans le réseau
mozaik qui avait des difficultés liées
au fait qu' il n'y avait pas de bus etc
la réponse qui a été vu par cette
direction est complètement et à côté
parce que finalement ça n'est pas ça du
tout aujourd'hui qu'est ce que nous
constatons la situation les conditions
de travail des salariés et est
complètement dégradée
de l'autre côté nous observons qui est
un détournement parce que c'est de ça
qu'il faut dit il ya un détournement
parce que vous avez des entreprises qui
ont des marchés qui aujourd'hui ont
peut-être trois quatre lignes eh bien
vous avez de vous
deux chauffeurs pour pour 3,4 ligne
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de bus
ben c'est monsieur là continuent à
percevoir les l'élimination des
subventions des prestations mais en
réalité par colis vous avez un du spo la
colline vous avez un bus pour l'emploi
vous avez un bus pour l'avenir tout ça
et bien il ya qu un seul bus qui fait le
service ne correspond pas voir la
facture présentée voilà en quels que
soient la sava voulaient entendre
oui services publics ont leurs
délégations tient ici on dit que tout le
monde ferme les yeux
tout le monde ferme les yeux parce que
ils sont pas en capacité justement en
tout cas le donneur d'ordre le
délégataire n'est pas capacité de
contraindre ces entreprises à respecter
les engagements et résultat de ce sont
les usagers qui en souffre
d'ailleurs je dois rappeler que pendant
plusieurs mois
on a vu que le service était alité
chaque fois est invité à 18 heures et on
ne vous a même rendu responsable associé
maroc est un héritage que nous sommes
pas présents dans l'entreprise
c'est fait alors ça c'est votre grille
de lecture par rapport au dossier à
l'organisation du transport en commun
par le passé la cstm était un syndicat à
ses proches en tout cas il a il avait en
son sein des gens qui étaient assez
proches du mime
on le sait on se souvient notamment on
va revenir à la marque pulvar puisque
vous allez lui rendre hommage dans
quelques jours dix ans après sa
disparition mais mais je le disais donc
fut un temps la cstm était assez proche
du mime et puis là vous avez aussi dans
votre ordre du jour me la suppression de
l'émission formation éducation des
travailleurs sur rld m qui est on le
rappelle radieux les v12 martinique donc
la radio du mime sur laquelle intervient
très fréquemment d'ailleurs alfred marie
jeanne
alors que vous êtes fâchés que le mime
qu'est ce qui se passe on vous a su créé
votre votre émission sur cette radio
rapidement il faut rapidement
personnellement j'ai jamais été au même
d'ailleurs depuis mon arrivée à
sestrières ça fait plus de 25 années il
n'y a pas d'option ne va pas demander
quel est votre couleur politique mais en
réalité vous avez raison de le lire
effectivement il ya un lien entre le
mime et la cstm historique
bon ça c'est une chose aujourd'hui il
faut savoir que la csdm depuis 32 ans a
quand même tenu cette émission de daniel
morissette n'a pu voir et j'en passe y
compris monein et puis le mois d'août
bien
alfred marie-jeanne décidé de supprimer
l'émission avant une décision
personnelle absolument absolument pas ce
qu'il faut savoir à ses manques de droit
de l'association qui gère le gac qui
gère la radio et que par conséquent nous
avons adressé un courrier au président
parce que je rappelle que le président
de l'association c'est n'est pas un
fromage et le président nous a pas
répondu nous allons demander mais nous
voulons savoir pourquoi
l'émission a été supprimé aujourd'hui on
n'a aucun n'a pas qu'une réponse soit
explications par des obligations sauf
que nous observons que il ya un
président de cour du conseil
d'administration nous sommes membres
doivent désigner radio 32 ans et qu'elle
se soit quelques dates en réalité qui me
savoir la personne de marie jeanne qui a
supprimé la radio d'oc il a fait une
mouture avec les travailleurs ce n'est
pas de communes avec les travailleurs et
ça montre bien le lien qui pourrait
exister entre les travailleurs et la
politique je me dis que la politique
aujourd'hui
en tout cas ils ont pris leurs marques
par rapport au travail ont alors
rapidement une trentaine de secondes
bertrand conduisit on y reviendra plus
longuement dans nos prochaines éditions
le 3 février prochain vous allez rendre
hommage à marc pulvar alors évidemment
responsable historique de la cstm
justement on en parlait il était membre
du mime aussi lui un moment il avait
laissé sur sur la fin mais donc hommage
rendu à marc pulvar
dix ans déjà
après son décès oui absolument dix ans
après nous avons nous avons compris
qu'il fallait rendre hommage et en
manque il va donc c'est un hommage
d'après nos qui est quand même un signe
de reconnaissance et que par conséquent
samedi 3 b il voit cet hommage
quand vous avez le programmateur à
rivière salée et la vague mendy à fort
de france
mais il y aura plus de précisions rester
à l'écouté voilà merci bertrand quand
celle ci est bonne journée à tous